oh I should have put my denim jacket on
so I look cool or do I just look wider
and I do this even I would hate me ma'am
you don't go to this high school and
what huggers do through W had no
nightmare life is different now I'm here
in Amsterdam as you can tell much
Amsterdam very Dutch this is my hotel
room but behind you is Amsterdam it's
bull [ __ ] yeah no green-screen see look
I can't keep that that well okay act to
me I'm here on the last day of VidCon EU
which has been so fun I'm in-between two
things that I have to do so I came back
to the hotel because I get tired being
around people introvert the definition
of he also me so I thought because it is
not the video on Friday because I will
get to that I thought I'd make a stream
of conscious video for you right now I
didn't post the video on Friday I wanted
to I have planned on it and then I got
food poisoning here in Amsterdam who
people gets in Helbig and by them I mean
my gastrointestinal system and by
guessing I mean not able to function
properly yep I got straight-up food
poisoning I haven't had food poisoning
in my life that I remember specifically
growing up until this New Year's Eve
2017 I got food poisoning at poops for
like eight hours and what I think with
Richard rockefeller I know it was
totally my fault I was being bougie and
it was bad
that joke was bad and again this time
totally my fault
I pushed the boundaries I was eating
cheese I was eating cream that was
eating dairy and I was eating veal when
it was told to me that it was steak but
then I wasn't finished it and someone
told me it was feeling and I just
continued to eat it so with all choices
that I could have made differently and I
did it and I went to bed and my stomach
hurt really bad and I woke up in a cute
four time and um I cry when I puke I cry
because my body is so this really out of
control
and it makes me upset her so my first
day of VidCon was a very gentle day but
I want to say thank you to everyone that
came to my meet-and-greet that first day
was so nice to me it doesn't feel a
little weird because I tweeted out that
I couldn't make it to my first panel
because that's a boys I know but I came
to me angry everyone was like are you
okay are you okay
hate that kind of attention because it
wasn't like the like no one did it to me
other than me I did it to me and so when
people were concerned for my health I
was like thank you but you have no
reason to be concerned because I hurt
myself like you worry about her things
like you know the state of the world not
the state of my digestive system but I
appreciate it so much
it doesn't not the easiest thing
colloquially and conversationally to say
oh yeah I was puking out in from my
mouth on my butthole
for the first couple hours of the
morning but I'm talking a lot better now
I haven't forgotten either orifice as of
late but we'll see here's something we
keep that up go team anyway ash and gray
are such nice people here it's unreal
everyone so polite and kind and calm and
consider it and I don't know if it's
because they're generally really a ok
people or if it's because then they just
handle everything with such care or
they're just so meditatively present and
tomorrow I don't know when this will go
up but tomorrow my Maria and Hannah and
I had to Iceland we're going on vacation
together the three of us have never
vacationed together / anything that
didn't have any work involved in itself
this might be the last time that you see
us all together the fun but because I
got food poisoning I did stock up on
varieties of crackers and toast part of
your tripod is another box of crackers
this is a new amount of ideas and
talking about how makes you crackers I
bought at the grocery store yesterday
this is real life this is authentic
transparent I'm at war red in a photo
you just photo that's a photo of me and
Laura yeah Wow my aura is that I'm
overwhelmed by a variety of like socks
and possibilities and that I'm in
performance mode which accurate as
Calvin Klein's beak that's here that
gave me this beautiful watch what what
and they had this woman that takes or
photographs in their suite where you put
your hands on this like sensory machine
you have to hold a pose for 10 seconds
and then you take a photo and when she
peels the photo back it reveals your
aura and look how like I'm concentrating
so hard and not moving in this photo and
maybe that's why my aura was overwhelmed
a little bit but I thought that was so
cool so thank you Calvin Klein for that
experience
cracker time a lot of bikes here
everyone you're in Amsterdam likes to
tell you the fact that there are more
bikes than people water turns out
something that you need to drink while
you're traveling I do mind that my
mailman was stopping me I had to
threaten him to get out of my house
holding two butter knives food poisoning
and stress dream traveling to Europe
look good on me did you see the variety
of new emoji the ones that confused me
the most were the men and women in a
sauna seemingly holding a spoon so
that's supposed to be a shower or spoon
sound of something I don't know about
that a youtube challenge that swept that
I missed out on while I was traveling
are you doing spoon fellas now is that
where we're at I have a shower and
probably like a spork around here
somewhere what's going on in your life
how's your day okay
seagulls seagulls here Biggles exist on
every single continent is there one
animal that exists on every single
continent I'm going to say to see well
quote me on that just kidding I had the
worst jetlag of my entire life on this
trip to the point that Mary and I
genuinely thought we had mono I think
that John Mayer song was about me my
body is a wonderland you wonder how it
still holds up as a body having I just
got to wit my own body odor Google and
from Mohammed I've been doing Instagram
story a lot lately and I've been
completely disregarding snapchat and I
feel a little remorse for it so tell me
what you guys prefer Instagram story or
snapchat leave a comment down below this
is really going to change the course of
my life in a very very specific and
grave way so I need you to be on as
short hair and I really care what you
think about it oh would you like a quick
tour of the hotel room you can't make
that choice I'm doing it for you here we
go that was a tripod in which you were
just not there is this thing down here
that's automated and luscious ready I
push this button the curtains closed but
only one of them is closing oh no both
of those clothes
I'll open back up that's the curtains
don't tell anyone and we don't that so
here's another fun manatee is that there
is this stool in the bathroom that is
covered in my towel material and I don't
know what it's for but I have been using
it as the fanciest squatty potty in all
the land something my hotels though
isn't I found no matter where you go
internationally or domestically the are
you can see that always looks like it
was purchased at a pier 1 imports no
offense I mean that better art than I
could ever do in my entire life Wow I
think the chair of consciousness Klaus
has gone on
enough and I will cut out much of this
but I hear so much for watching if you
like the extreme conscious vlog like I
like making them please let me know in
the comments down below give this video
a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes you've seen but last week's
schedule other than that I don't know
there's a boat on the canal a lot of
balloons on that's obnoxious as the
obnoxious American housing hummus and
rice grape into her mouth as she went
too hard on cheese if she gave herself
food poisoning so you're being obnoxious
boat